we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's go to the 5 7 0 area code Pat if
you'll indulge me for a moment
caller what's your name and where are
you calling from today hi my name is
Jason I'm calling from Pennsylvania
what's on your mind today Jason I
decided to get your opinion on something
specifically about the Supreme Court
more specifically about the method by
which Supreme Court justices are
appointed okay Tom what do you think
about the idea of taking the power to
nominate and confirm Supreme Court
justices excuse me
away from the president and the Senate
and instead having Supreme Court
justices be directly elected by the
American people I am against that for a
couple different reasons number one it
would be almost impossible but let's
pretend it were possible right let's
let's put the logistics aside for a
second Pat I am sort of against the idea
of Supreme Court seats being political
now you could say David you're being
naive the president decides who to put
in there if you've got a Democratic
president they put in a more
left-leaning judge if you've got a
Republican president they put in a
right-leaning judge if you've got a
Democratic president in their last year
then Republicans just delay and wait
until you've got a Republican president
in there to make a decision so it's
already political why don't we just
change it from one way of being
political to another but I think that a
listen if you see how uninformed voters
are in a presidential election every
four years which supposedly would be
something people would pay attention to
and care about I just have no confidence
whatsoever that letting the public vote
on a Supreme Court justice would do
anything positive for us I don't think
that judges should be elected officials
and that's something that goes on even
at the local and state level obviously
probably shouldn't happen at the federal
level I can't imagine a judge going out
there and trying to campaign and trying
to gather support I mean when are you
going to go after like you know I'm for
fairness I'm for being strict when it
comes to the law you have to go down
specific policy issues right I just
don't want to see any of them especially
when if you believe this sort of
idealistic notion of the law which is
the judge
are there not because of their leanings
but because they are merely going to
apply the law to the facts of a case
what are they going to campaign on right
I mean obviously we know that it doesn't
work this way but you should have if
someone understands the law then that's
how that's what should determine how
they apply the law to particular cases
so you're basically asking for more
political applications or
interpretations of law by having judges
campaign and I agree at the local level
I'm totally against it anyway that's my
thoughts I appreciate the call thank you
very much for taking it all right